ah it's me all right this is the one
this is the one is the moment the the
game that won't end no no no seriously
there it is crazy
yeah I also don't know much about her
chest let's pull up her player card
um I I have to tell you when I read this
I I it's like I'm so used to seeing TSM
spelled out so she she signed to team
solo mid I didn't realize we were going
by like legal names she's got nearly 100
uh not 100 I would say a million nearly
a million followers uh on Twitch just
like me I think I have 998 000 so I'm
I'm close too uh and uh she's trilingual
she speaks English Korean and Chinese
I'm only bilingual
uh I know that's that's a big thing he's
uh always lifting weights you can't
travel when you have to spend so much
time in the gym because he has gigantic
muscles like it really does they are
enormous um he's the League of Legends
streamer of the year the last two years
I'm the chess streamer of the Year by
the way uh runner-up is my co-host uh
Tyler uh he's the host he hosts the
Tyler one championship series
and he's a former running back at
Central they had no third bullet they
had to talk about his football career
yeah no I have to say the football the
trilingual these are like great facts
they dug I mean my goodness is that
gonna help him today how fast he can run
on the chessboard I don't know one of
these must one of these must she played
the Queen's Pawn Tyler played a move so
fast that he has more than 10 minutes
and I think his goal might be to end the
game with 11 minutes on the clock
because he's playing very fast
is a speed machine you know he's not
going to slow down for chess
like that's a crazy thing to like that's
such a specific lie that I mean it
almost makes sense based on this
gameplay the G4 the bishop in front of
e3 I I think she is improvising on her
openings
yeah I don't think yeah yeah I don't
think oh and Tyler just snapped snaps
that pawn off the board yeah Duda I
don't think
would have prepared her in Bishop to E3
uh could be a new one we maybe just
don't know about it yet yup we don't
know it could be the next big opening
Bishop takes is a very nice move
is he speaking or are those
text-to-speech alerts
swap for Bishop and then I can take this
never heard him so badly take his Queen
it's not bad right so I go here what's
he gonna take this
no
this no it's a good move let's go yeah
let's go back to the big screen actually
he he's got a really good position
I also uh
he played Bishop to H6 which is fine as
long as he finds this move
his accuracy right now is 93 percent
yep and here you could try to create
some weaknesses around the king Take the
bishop just don't hang the bishop on H6
and he has a beautiful plan of attack on
the king
yeah as long as he exactly as long as he
sees this he'll be all right but
oh I don't know I don't know if he's
gonna be all right the thing is when
you're when you're really really a
beginner like 200 you you can't even get
yourself to make trades because you're
like if I take they take me
and I don't want them to take me but
like you can't play chess like that like
and he doesn't okay very nice I if he
finds it nope not scared at all yeah if
I was dude I'd be pissed right now oh
yeah Duda really needs to uh um
so
this is
this is literally running it down mid
basically
is that what the gamers do oh that's a
football thing running down mid
right I thought that was a gaming term
no but I don't know I thought that was
more of a football analogy yeah that's
okay
oh I see
oh you saw it
he played the best move and it might
hurt her screen had a little bit of a
robotic melt down there um
that's a great move from Tyler and
Knight takes Knight is just a clean win
of a night
yeah Tyler's putting on the pressure and
Jenny meanwhile is eating the nights so
I don't know if we can defend about this
and this
Tyler has played 12 moves at a 90
accuracy uh Queen G3 yeah he's he's
really he's really
he's really doing a nice job Knight
takes Knight is is clean Queen takes
night is clean oh my goodness he left no
crumbs
59.
259 is crazy oh look at look at this
side by side view look at this
production
wow players locked in focused Tyler just
Tyler just cooking it up here I think
we're gonna listen in on time
it's murphing us
the trade
yeah Queen takes rook and then like Rook
G8 I mean it but this game's not over
you could totally still hang something
does he see Queen takes Rook
I have to say I I underestimated him
he's seen everything he keeps taking the
pieces
oh and now she has to go Queen takes
Knight which is findable
I think he's he's an unsuspected Prodigy
look at this uh a bishop sack you might
think he's giving a free Bishop no he is
baiting the king to get mated on G3 and
we will have a mate within the next 10
moves yeah I mean to be honest Bishop
takes H3 is uh it is it looks like you
just lose a bishop but it's the third
move of the engine okay that's actually
crazy I was just
no it's because the king is out and
queen G3 is mate now the rookie because
he hasn't seen it the entire game so
this is yeah a very testing moment it's
not easy to see and he hasn't seen it
yet I don't know if the ties will turn
just yet yeah he has to find I mean he
lost the bishop thinking that he had
like a trick but
Ah that's no not like this no that was
not what we needed where's wrong pieces
castling is good but not right okay so
he just lost with one move his accuracy
went down by 12 percent
that's so sad because he's probably so
proud like yes I'm castling I'm doing
the principles no completely losing move
I'm not losing but not no not losing
that he missed clicked wait
oh oh yeah can we see him yes
is he still a little bit better Cody on
the website guys a little bit
I meant to move my I didn't want to
Castle I wanted to move my castle right
here
thank you so can we unmute this man what
happened he had touched this King and
now he went to move his Rook
and just then he's my next Prodigy
chess.com has done this to me they've
done this to me too they've done this to
me too I touched the king I don't want
to move the king anymore and then I try
to go to the rook and it auto castles
you because the things that when you
touch your king and then touch your Rook
it once you it's still gonna make it
happen though I love it yes look at this
very tilting I would be very tilted oh
my god
um
look at that look at that look but he's
still doing it he gave her three moves
and the attack is still so strong that
he's gonna mate this is amazing
well there's a what queen F4
no you made it on G2 sorry I'm zoned out
wow just over
there's no way to defend
yeah wow Queen G3 I mean uh yeah five
you get attacked let's see if Jenny
Jenny needs to her only hope is to put a
piece on the sign of fire that's mate
uh okay
he wants style points he is too cool to
mate with the queen he wants to mate
with the Rook he misses me and now this
is made
but this is
King H1 I he might lose the I mean
it's close it's very tight like you
gotta go here
yeah it gets kind of tricky it's not
that obvious
it's a 50 50. it depends where Jenny's
gonna go no
Ginny is forced to find The Rook because
she has no other moves she has to take
it
he loses the Rook by force
and now he has to play Rook G8 is he
cerebral enough to recover
yeah let's tune in I guess
I believe it's Jenny's move this is the
this is the best chess game I've ever
seen Queen to C3 check she's had 20
minutes to come up with a move by the
way yeah let's not forget I was curious
what they were gonna spend their time on
I think that they're both trying to make
a plan
um we'll see what they came up with they
spent all this time calculating and
coming up with great plans
no Queen C3 yeah he he he's got he's got
a little bit of extra time I mean we're
we're back in game mode here that's
extremely impressive wow that's
Sensational ah it's mate
seriously
okay the good news is this is the only
move and Knight takes Queen is made by
accident Knight takes Queen is made by
it's over
all right that was a good one Jenny
looks actually like horrified
D4 Knight A6 now this obviously you know
you want to play for the center with the
pawns and the Knights which is exactly
what uh Tyler's doing Knight A6 has been
played quite a bit by you know strong
players like Carlson and ah yes you
think she brushed up on her Magnus
Theory yeah she's playing the Australian
defense has Ginny actually streamed from
Australia I feel like I wouldn't be
surprised maybe she's preparing for I
did a thing he's uh he's the only
Australian in the group
so this is a real opening and you're not
trolling people actually play Knight A6
F5
no def they definitely don't play a five
but after a five it's kind of a Dutch
defense it's D4 F5 and then Knight C3
Knight A6 I mean it's edgy stuff you
know it's it's not cutting edge Theory
but you know I have four of each
blocking in the bishop a little bit now
black is just fantastic there you go
she's making it work she did go to
Australian stream that's awesome
honestly if I can stream in one place it
would be Australia because there's lots
of animals and it's probably the most
dangerous place
yeah there's a lot of animals like
spiders and jellyfish
and uh snakes and so on one day oh I can
I could see you fighting a kangaroo yeah
me too Alex wanted to go do a boat as a
broad episode and be professional spider
Hunters always hunt the most dangerous
spiders
maybe they'll be my next calling
that that that is USA literally has guns
there
I'm talking about the animals we're not
oh she's undeveloped the night uh she
was not convinced of the night's
positioning on the edge of the board
um she really she she should try to get
more pieces into the game so what I tell
beginners is like nine times out of ten
going backwards is not the best move
um you've got a better move going
forward yeah that's made uh but you but
that's no longer made but that's a free
Queen because it's completely trapped
that would have been a nice one
instead he went D5 and now if the
servers disconnect we're going to be
here for another 50 moves the bishop is
blocked uh but this is still defended
he's still doing very very well
um
but Knight F7 was a clean triple fork
for tyler1 hitting the queen and the
rook and the bishop but oh
even some puzzles ah
it just keeps getting better and better
now we take the knights check
King maybe moves maybe we even get that
Knight back in F7 unless she blocks but
when he did he did just play this so
it's a natural follow-up for Tyler and
like he said he knows what he's doing I
think he's gonna take the knights
I yeah I don't know I mean he just went
here he was threatening to take the
Knight
I I think
I
took the Knight what a beast
what a beast and it's a discover check
this is good I was really starting to
get worried like
I know he plays League of Legends and he
likes the pain but you have to take the
piece at some point
uh does Jenny know it's a discover check
like does she she's gonna try to take
this and then the thing is gonna go me
like it doesn't show should we tune in
all right F7 you you would sack The Rook
but you know it's it's a it's a cheeky
Fork
Knight F7 is a it's the best move it
picks up a rook or or more if black
doesn't take you can I don't know Tyler
didn't see it earlier so might not
happen yeah he just keeps taking here's
the here's my problem with this move
you're you're giving your opponent's
Bishop way too much scope
activating the sniper indeed
what The Rook can be taken and oh no
that he's gotta quit on the board he's a
magician doesn't need the mate he
doesn't need the queen he doesn't need
anything the man just promoted and moved
like 15. yet the pawn just walked
through it couldn't be taken on C6 it
needed to be taken on B7 yeah I listen a
bit of fatigue for sure also isn't Jenny
in Europe it's 140 in the morning very
late for Ginny very very late poor God
that's that's not nice that we've
stalled the match out I mean he's got a
queen now he's got a
he's he's got a he's gotta keep the
queen safe there are two queens just
standing around
I think Genie is going to strategically
tie up all her pieces and Orient
orientate the queens in a perfect
structure
all she has to do is get rid of these
pawns and she is she is getting this
tell me I can't even this Chestnut come
overlay I'm looking at I can't even tell
how much material he's up how much
material is white up
a lot
I legitimately can't tell okay I didn't
go to I didn't go to college for a
reason don't make me do more math than I
have to
all right black has nine points this is
nine right here so it's 5 10 19 24 oh
it's more than that now 28. thanks Chad
I do math when you have human computers
that look at this setup for the ladder
mate oh look at that setup for the
ladder mate oh my God Mrs stalemate by
just a second this is crazy
a second some pawns that was it yeah and
stuff
that was a very clean and convincing
game
yeah baby
and you guys
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
okay
by the way I won nine straight by the
way nine straight
he won nine straight games for parents
yes sir yes sir I told you when the
pressure is on I perform who cares about
all those games throughout the week I
was warming up
I can still hear him uh Tyler won with a
monster performance the first two zero
of the day both other matches had at
least one draw he never left any doubt
and I gotta tell you I was prepared I
was looking at everyone's Scouting
Report before the event and he's an
underdog in group C but after this
performance I'm not sure I mean he's
knocking on the door for xqc squeaks is
gonna have to be looking out Tyler won
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign